Hello everybody, this is Dr. Kevin Conner's and Conner's clinic live again, and I want to share
another question that people have said, and again, if you have questions, please send them to info
at Conner's clinic.com. The question came in as vitamin E good for cancer. There's mixed data out
there, and vitamin E with all sorts of health issues. Vitamin E is very good for the arteries,
but it's a specific form of vitamin E that's good for the arteries. Matter of fact, there was a study
a few years ago that said that vitamin E is not good for your heart, stop taking it,
problem is they use the wrong form of vitamin E in the study. There's some hypothesis that
they purposely use the wrong form of vitamin E in the study because they knew it wouldn't work.
Size of fact, we want to understand the different types of vitamin E. Vitamin E in nature
has four outer components and four inner components. The outer components are called the Tocopharaus,
and that's typically what you're going to see in a supplement if you go to the store and buy a
vitamin E supplement. I'll say alpha Tocophara, or mixed Tocophara, or alpha beta gamma delta Tocophara.
But it's the Tocophara that are not the ones you want to use. If you have heart conditions,
it's not the ones that you want to use for cancer. It's the inner portion of the vitamin E. Those are
the Tocotryanols, kind of confusing. The Tocotryanols are the inner portions and the Tocopharaus
are the outer portions. It's very easy to synthesize those outer portions. The Tocopharaus in the
laboratory, that's why you're going to see them in store bought vitamins usually. The Tocotryanols,
the inner portion, and it's typically, that's not typically, it's specifically the gamma and delta
Tocotryanols. That are the imported components of the vitamin E that is good for cancer and good
for the heart. There's several studies of the gamma and delta Tocotryanols for cancer, and for
the heart, and you can certainly just Google scholar those studies as well. They're very impressive.
We use a product that's called, we actually, a private label that's called,
Apple E300, this one right here. I personally take this for my cancer as well. It's got 300 milligrams
of the gamma and delta, inner portion of the vitamin E that you want for cancer. It is good for
your heart as well. I highly recommend that for all our cancer patients. It's certainly the type
of the vitamin E that you want to take. Matter of fact, there's a danger in taking just the outer
portion of the vitamin E because you only have certain absorption sites for your nutrients, especially
the fat-soluble nutrients. It's more difficult to absorb. When you're taking a synthetic
Tocotryanols, outer portion of the vitamin E, which is typically what you're going to get most
inexpensive supplements, and even some good supplements that they're just appealing to the masses,
those will take the absorption sites of the inner portion vitamin E molecule. If you're getting
that in your food, and they can actually, they'll decrease absorption of the Tocotryanols.
I know it's confusing, but you want to get the inner portion of the Tocotryanols, the gamma and
the delta Tocotryanols that are going to be the beneficial for the vitamin E for your heart,
for your arteries, and for cancer. If this helps, I ask you to like this, share this on Facebook,
and with your friends. Thanks so much, Dr. Cutters, and we'll talk to you soon.